it's a conspiracy theory that I'm
actually interested in Britney Spears is
speaking her mind and accusing the
paparazzi of doctoring photos hello and
please don't judge me I look Haggard
right now but my question to all of you
is a lot of fans and our world today
they always are subject to really
criticize people and say that the
pictures and videos that they're posting
are either not on time or they're fake
that's Brit Brit on IG story Sunday
claiming paparazzi edited photos of her
on vacation with boyfriend Samish Gauri
in Miami no one ever really asked are
the paparazzi pictures fake into the
paparazzi people do stuff with the
pictures and is the news really real
it's a conspiracy theory that I'm
actually interested in this is the pink
Britney's talking about and in her insta
she goes on to say the shot makes her
look heavier than she actually is I look
like a 40 pounds bigger than I am today
this is how I am right now and I'm
skinny as a needle you tell me okay
first of all guys I love Britney I
literally have a photo of her and I on
my desk but this is a little confusing I
think part of being famous means that
there could be some bad paparazzi shots
of you once in a while and I think
Britney noses too
[Music]
and we know Britt is in good shape just
last week she posted this epic video
dancing to Billie eyelashes bad guy even
in this shot taken during the vacation
Britt looks adorable in her coverup
while Sam went shirtless
[Music]
britt story is just the latest since her
return to social media in recent weeks
it's been a roller coaster year as she
completed a stay at a health facility in
April and has been dealing with a string
of legal issues surrounding her
conservatorship you know you hold on to
family when you go through hard times
like that but amid questions from
worried fans she did assure us she's in
control of her Instagram for those of
you who don't think I post my own videos
I did this video yesterday so you're
wrong but hope you like it a source
recently told et that when it comes to
Brits insta sometimes her people are a
little concerned about how she comes
across but quote right now Brittany
would like to exercise her right to do
whatever she pleases all right guys what
do you make of Brittany's latest
Instagram post let me know and for all
the latest on Brent keep it locked to
all things et until next time I'm Katie
Krauss and bye for now
[Applause]
[Music]